aid workers and emergency responders
know what to do when hundreds of
thousands of people are in need the
problem in Mozambique is getting the aid
to the people who need it
Sky News boarded a soviet-era helicopter
chartered by the World Food Program it's
Ukrainian crew taking family size tents
and survival meals to a town called nama
tanda but first we had to cross the
giant Inland Sea the product of cyclone
EDI and five days of torrential rain
the weather wasn't the only complication
we were traveling to a remote community
and the pilots couldn't find it the
floodwaters had swallowed up the
landmarks on their Maps
with fuel running low the crew had
little choice they decided to return to
base difficult isn't it okay equipped
with a new set of coordinates we flew
once more for nama tender and this time
we found it a handful of residents
signaling from the landing zone by the
time we touched down thousands had
arrived to greet us this the first aid
delivery to reach the town we're in a
really bad situation we don't have
anything to cover us and everything is
in water including our food our
helicopter it was swiftly unloaded in
front of a large and expectant audience
but our cargo was grossly inadequate
more than ten thousand families in this
district have lost their homes and
they're disappointed there's no hope for
them the man who runs this district told
me he was feeling the pressure he simply
can't meet the people's basic needs is
this enough or do you need more help we
need more because we're not talking only
about these residents everybody into
this tree there are people in other
areas we still can't bring them food by
car support of sheikh waheed they've
unloaded everything in about 10 minutes
not very long and we've got to go these
guys have got another mission to do and
we'll leave these people behind
I don't think they want us to go this is
not the best way to deliver aid lorries
carry much more cargo but in flood-hit
mozambique it's the best way and the
only way to keep people alive John
sparks Sky News Mozambique